back after he throws it in bounds  [Applause]  burton crossover pull-up jumpers up  overtime  i don't see either side celebrating the  overtime here  in their final so their regular season  is not over yet  i think 101 96 in a  thankfully rapidly moving overtime  [Applause]  two-man game with noah mann stops  fires oh my goodness give this young man  the key to the city  25 for terence man  oh man you're just so happy for him  you're just so happy for me you see  kawhi leonard right there saying you  need one assist young fella  go get a pick and roll with pat pat i  guarantee you he's telling him that  but speaking of patpat it just paid off  for him  get to the paint you got a shooter in  the corner  if they make a mistake you make them pay  [Music]  i really am happy for these young guys  we saw